car bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin sur rtl france
alors on l'a vu cette refonte du système
peut être une menace à l'échelle
nationale sur l'éducation dans les zones
les plus reculées notamment concrètement
quelles pourraient en être les
conséquences si vous voulez le
gouvernement nous vend qui veut
globalisé l'éducation prioritaire
le poème city souhaite pas mettre des
mots des moyens supplémentaires non
c'est à dire qu'on va prendre les moyens
qui sont aujourd'hui à louer on allait
diluer sur l'ensemble du territoire
ça veut dire qu'on aura un réseau
d'éducation prioritaire qui sera
détricoter et qui sera plus aussi
efficace dans les quartiers qui en ont
le plus besoin
parce qu'aujourd'hui les réseaux verts
et la plus il fonctionne là où les
enfants le plus de difficultés là où les
familles sont les plus précaires
là où les enfants aussi parfois on
discutait avec l'apprentissage de la
langue française et il a des résultats
qui sont satisfaisants qui sont parfois
un parfait mais en fonction des
territoires et moi je vois dans
territorial fort des résultats tout à
fait satisfaisants dans les deux
collèges ray qui sont concernés ça
serait vraiment une catastrophe que ce
que ce réseau rêve soit soit détricoté
chez nous justement quand on fait un
petit peu le bilan de dd rép
il n'est pas forcément positif peut être
chez vous à belfort mais on voit qu'il
ya encore un écart de niveau qui est
très important qu'est ce qui coince
encore aujourd'hui un problème de
pilotage
messieurs les autres on se trouve sur le
diagnostic on voit qu'ils encore un
écart de niveau mon prend des élèves qui
sont beaucoup plus en difficulté que les
autres et à la fin du répond diversion
en difficulté donc ça marche pas moi je
pense que c'est des enfants qui seraient
encore plus en difficulté aujourd'hui
ces aides auraient pu ne fonctionnait
pas on a par endroits des difficultés je
pense notamment la région parisienne des
vraies difficultés une mixité qui
peuvent qui peuvent perdurer
parce qu'effectivement ces réseaux rêves
sont dans les sons dans les banlieues
les plus difficiles de notre territoire
elle met dans les autres départements
chez nous ça re créer de la mixité parce
qu'en faisant de ces établissements où
autrefois difficiles des établissements
d'excellence
on a ramené les enfants des villages à
venir dans les collèges qui sont au
coeur du quartier
on a ramené des élèves à avoir des
résultats qui sont bien plus
satisfaisant qu'ailleurs moi d'ailleurs
on a un collège
ici le collège vauban classée au glacis
qui est menacé de sortir yonhap non pas
à cause de la réforme et parce que ses
résultats sont considérablement
améliorées et sont aujourd'hui et parmi
les meilleurs du département parce qu'on
ya mis les moyens
et tout est question moi n'est en
réalité moi j'ai tout à fait d'accord
pour qu'on mette plus
moyens dans les écoles et dans les
collèges ruraux ce qui manquait
notamment ces dernières années mais ça
doit pas se faire au détriment de ceux
de nos enfants qui sont le plus en
difficulté aujourd'hui parce que c'est
un devoir de solidarité nationale pour
le revoir alors votre autre inquiétude
porte sur le processus d'attribution des
moyens de ces contrats locaux et peut-il
y avoir un déséquilibre et surtout qui
au sein de chaque académie choisira
d'attributs et elle le vit un tel
établissement
on voit bien que ça va se faire au coup
par coup sévère sur l'état de l'année
précédente ça va faire en fonction
peut-être des moyens de pression de
telle ou telle mère par rapport aux
recteurs mais en tout cas ça va poser
des questions et puis ça dit contrat de
trois ans pour qu'un réseau rep et des
résultats il faut des années des années
il faut l'engagement concret d'une
équipe éducative faut l'engagement des
parents d'élèves il faut l'engagement
des chefs d'établissement qui
extrêmement volontaire et sur trois ans
on n'aura pas les résultats
on n'aura pas des résultats
satisfaisants c'est à dire qu'on va
faire le boulot pendant trois ans et
puis après on va repartir mais si elles
mêmes problématiques qu'avant dans
certains collèges les mêmes difficultés
reviendront admirablement merci beaucoup
et yann bouchard d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
député et maire de belfort